your question you answer mine it's
actually not my job to answer your
questions are you prepared to call h a
terror group is it possible to have a
rational I've asked you two questions
should a mass stay in power and are they
a terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV it's the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV I'm Douglas Murray on uncensored
tonight prince Andrew Bill Clinton and
Professor Steven Hawking are among the
high-profile people named in bombshell
documents connected to Jeffrey Epstein
but are we missing the most important
figure in all of this Jeffrey Epstein
himself we'll
investigate and do court cases and
ballot bans only make Donald Trump's
chances of winning the White House
stronger we'll look forward to the US
presidential election that will shape
the world and from James Bond to Doctor
Who are trigger warnings and an
obsession with inclusion and diversity
ruining our most loved shows actor and
comedian James draus will join me
[Music]
live live from the news building in
London this is Pierce Morgan
uncensored good evening and welcome to
uncensored where it's my final night
holding the fort for peers he's going to
be back on air next week however if
you're missing Mr Morgan's hot takes on
the really big topics then he is still
very active on social media here's one
of his overnight posts we're 3 days into
the transfer window and Arsenal still
haven't signed a striker or even made a
move for one what the hell are you
waiting for artia arteta well we're all
thinking it aren't we even if we're not
saying it anyway onto other matters and
there really is only one place to start
this evening Court files and documents
containing previous ly hidden identities
of people associated in some way with
the late notorious sex offender Jeffrey
Epstein are now unsealed and the names
revealed are a mix of the scandalous
President Bill Clinton and prince Andrew
the surprising Professor Steven Hawking
and the truly surreal David Copperfield
the magician now the first thing that
has to be said is that the inclusion of
a name in the documents doesn't mean
that that person is guilty of any
illegality or indeed
inappropriateness but let's be honest
being on jeffy's secret list isn't
something you'll be rushing to put in
the hobbies and interests section of
your CV overall however my take on this
dark story is that even with the list
now out in public there are still more
questions than ansers and the number one
question for me is this who exactly was
Jeffrey
Epstein was he merely a very rich sex
offender with a lot of famous friends
who enjoyed taking a ride on his private
airplane or visiting his luxury island
or was there something else going on one
Theory which I myself have heard from
trusted Associates is that Jeffrey
Epstein was an invention deliberately
and carefully created by those who
wanted to keep an eye perhaps even a
leash on the rich and Powerful here's a
a friend of mine the physicist Eric
Weinstein talking to my guest from
yesterday Chris Williamson about his
meeting Jeffrey Epstein for the first
time and my take on it instantly was
this is not an actual
human this is a construct of someone's
someone has created a fake human being
called Jeffrey Epstein who's a
mysterious currency trading Finance here
with Crazy rules so that no one would
ever invest with him and I think that
was to keep people from seeking his
Investment Services I mean he you know
he's labeled disgraced financier but
nobody has a record of trading with
him and so the theory goes Epstein was
an asset created in order to trap
powerful people in compromising
positions which could then be used in
order to control them the Russians call
that compromat.ru and they are very good
at it now I don't know if this is even
close to being true but I will say this
in 2024 simply claiming something is a
conspiracy theory doesn't necessarily
make it false not anymore and the more
that comes out about Epstein including
still very mysterious circumstances
surrounding his death in custody means
that I'm willing to at least consider
alternative narratives other than the
one being fed to us through offici
channels now joining me now is the
author and investigative journalist
Vicky Ward the author of war against the
Jews and Jeffrey Epstein's former lawyer
Alan dtz and the man I mentioned in my
monologue physicist and podcaster Eric
Weinstein thank you all so much for
being with me uh tonight first of all
Vicky Ward if I may you wrote uh
commissioned to write an incredibly
important article way back in
2003 about uh Jeffrey Epstein it was
called The Talented Mr Epstein and
you've since said that there were
significant efforts to sort of keep some
of your Revelations out what exactly
happened
there well you know what happened there
was Jeffrey Epstein um you know he was
an extraordinary manipulator not just of
uh young vulnerable women but of Rich
powerful men and you know uh what
happened in my reporting was that uh you
know I still don't know all of the
details but I had uh the on the record
allegations of uh two sisters two women
um and you know those those allegations
were cut from uh my story and you know
Jeffrey Epstein had gone to Great
Lengths to meet with then editor editor
of uh
Vanity Fair um and at the same time you
know Jeffrey Jeffrey epon was a
formidable person uh to write about you
know he he threatened me I was pregnant
with my children and he told me that if
he didn't like what I wrote he would uh
have a witch doctor place a curse on my
unborn children he told me he'd found
out where I was giving birth uh you know
I I I add this didn't stop me from
reporting the absolute uh best that I
could and I did debunk some of the
claims he made about his own Financial
professional life um but you know the
whole thing was Douglas a
nightmare can I ask you also Vicki just
quickly um were there any of the names
that released today which surprised
you no I didn't know about um David
Copperfield and I don't think I'd read
um about Stephen Hawking but no they
didn't
they didn't surprise me I mean you know
I've been covering this story for over
two decades so I was very familiar with
a lot of this I mean what it just did
was solidify a picture by putting
specific names in places but I think
that unfortunately the documents still
don't show a different part of Jeffrey
Epstein's life which is the manipulation
of the powerful people it was it was a
horrific portrait of uh this horrific
sexual subculture in his homes but it
didn't explain why people like Bill
Clinton um and massive philanthropists
like Leslie Wexner why they wanted to be
around this man and I'm sure your other
guests are going to have a lot of
insight into that because it it wasn't
because he had a whole group of of
underage women around him um thank you
Vick can I just come next to Alan dtz um
thank you so much Professor D for being
with us um first of all of course you
were Epstein's lawyer at one point and
you were also named in these uh released
documents today how do you respond to
this well first of all the woman who
accused me has now admitted that she may
have confus me with someone else may
have been a case of mistaken identity
and she's dropped all of her legal
charges I first met Jeffrey FC and I was
introduced to him by the lady Rothchild
um and uh um asked me to meet him
because he was a major contributor to
Harvard and I agreed to meet with him
and I went to some seminars that he
conducted at Harvard with president of
Harvard with major major academic
figures but from the day I met Jeffrey
Epsy until the day he died I have had
sexual contact with one woman and one
woman only my wife and so I was one of
those who wanted these papers to be
released my disappointment is that only
some have been released I want
everything to be released because they
will conf confirm the fact that I did
nothing wrong and they would also shed
light on other people who have been uh
accused some truthfully some uh false
some falsely but um the key point is
that uh we can't have just partial uh
releases of material in many of these
cases the accusation is there but the
rebuttal is not there or the disproof is
not there so for the public to form a
valid judgment um you need a full
release I don't need that because in my
case the woman who accused me has
admitted that she may have mistaken me
for someone else but I think others may
very well need the full evidence to be
exculpated and to prove some don't want
it because they may very well on that
very just very quickly I mean President
Clinton is mentioned more than 50 times
in these documents and he maintains he
never visited Epstein's Island uh Donald
Trump's also mentioned in there but uh
should do you think politicians and
others should explain their exact links
with Jeffrey
Epstein yeah for examp I'll give you a
story I was having dinner this is a name
dropping story with Caroline Kennedy the
former president's daughter and her
husband and Bill Clinton and another
couple and the phone rang this was on
Martha's Vineyard and the secret he was
President the Secret Service gave him
the phone he went away walked for about
15 minutes had a vibrant conversation I
didn't hear it and then he came back
with the phone and saying Allan somebody
wants to say hello to you and he handed
me the phone it was Jeffrey eping so
this was way before any accusations or
anything was suggested about EP but
obviously Clinton and EP had a
friendship and in most cases in my
example my friendship totally terminated
the day the accusations came out I did
serve as his lawyer but never again
socialized with him once I had heard
these accusations I think that's
probably true of some people in other
cases people continued to have a
friendship with him even after he served
his sentence in prison and they do have
some EXP explaining to do but that
doesn't prove guilty just bad let let me
bring in Eric Weinstein has been
patiently waiting in La Eric we uh we
heard earlier a bit of uh your
description of Jeffrey Epstein you met
him once more than 20 years ago can you
just quickly briefly recap what your
impression
was uh simply that um he uh was
introduced to me um in a financial
context I was uh
interested in investment in a so-called
uh carry trade in foreign exchange he
didn't seem to have any interest in that
uh he said that he was a uh currency
Trader uh there was no obvious evidence
that he was a currency Trader he didn't
speak like one um and he seemed to be
very interested as per the uh previous
comment about Stephen Hawking um in my
work on what might be called post
einsteinian physics in particular if you
check out his sponsorship of a
conference that he held in the Virgin
Islands called confronting
gravity um he was very interested
in um science this obviously is an area
with potential military applications
it's uh he was a very strange person
from beginning to end I don't really
believe this when you say that that he
was a strange person I describe some of
the things that were odd in that first
meeting that meet that one meeting
sure I don't hear anyone mention the
fact that he used an American flag as a
tablecloth making his dinner table
looked like both a coffin and a trap for
you to stain the flag of your own
country uh he brought in a woman who um
I think he introduced as an ays uh who
was braess that he bounced on his uh leg
at a financial meeting uh in an attempt
to create a
distraction uh the whole thing was
completely surreal from beginning to end
I think one thing that you can learn
about this is that he created an
incredibly uh intriguing World there was
no hint I think this was like 20 2003
2004 so this before he gets into trouble
in
Florida um and you know the whole thing
was like a scene out of a movie and you
both wanted to be nowhere close and to
know everything about it and I walked
out of there called my wife and said uh
I just met a human being who does not
appear to be a normal human being he
appears to be a construct somebody
appears to have constructed something
that looks like a finance here but if
you scratch the surface doesn't behave
like one doesn't seem to know a lot
about science although he's very
interested in science nothing made any
sense up was down left was right black
was white well we're going to have to
take a short break but I want to keep
all three of you here because I want to
get back after the break into this
really crucial question of who Jeffrey
Epstein actually might have been who do
we think he was we'll be talking about
that and much more after the
[Music]
break we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog turn you know what I love
about talk today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and rishy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swear an o in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million4 140
million so far so £40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for a liit if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan she have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man MC mous man he should be easy enough
to catch this guy shouldn't he I mean
he's got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
Phil sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party
hi kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved
this is really unfair what what what's
unfair if it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to Res yes CU I cannot continue my
work when I say I am God I'm not joking
did you feel Elvis was controlling I've
been answering your question you answer
mine it's actually not my job to answer
your questions are you prepared to call
h a terror group is it possible to have
a rational I've asked you two questions
should aass stay in power and are they a
terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV it's the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
[Music]
that welcome back to uncensored still
with me today our author and
investigative journalist Vicky Ward
author of the war against the Jews and
Jeffrey Epstein's former defense lawyer
Alan dtz and the physicist Eric
Weinstein let me just very quickly Eric
I just wanted to ask you quickly uh what
you were saying before the break what's
the actual allegation you're making who
do you think Jeffrey Epstein actually
was I don't know that's a great question
um but I knew that he wasn't who he said
he was almost from the instant I started
speaking to him um if I had to make a
guess and you're calling for speculation
I would say that he really belonged to
uh what is almost certainly the covert
operations community and um that he uh
did not appear to have a prime broker
nobody seemed to have traded with him
nobody uh seems to ask questions uh
around him so it's very suspicious that
we don't for example ask for form 13f if
he was a major hedge fund Trader it's
almost impossible to move through the
markets without leaving awake uh if have
to speculate I would say that he
probably belonged to covert operations
uh for one or more um Nations and that
what we're looking at is a very strange
you can shake your head Allan but it's
also the case that I don't necessarily
believe that you stopped associating
with him personally uh at the time of
his um conviction in Florida because uh
I think there are pictures of you at the
um program for revolutionary dynamic
uh socializing with Pinker triers I
don't know you tell me I'm gonna have to
go back to Alan dtz on that Alan dwiz
how do you respond all before that uh no
he was not a member of any intelligence
agencies I'm I'm quite sure of that um
and uh he was not a hedge fund guy in
fact once this is a you never want to
tell humerous stories about Jeffrey
Epstein but he once said to me he wanted
to sue a newspaper of for defamation I
said why did they call you a pedophile
he said no called me a hedge fund guy uh
he was very upset at being called a
hedge fund guy um I don't know what his
financial business was but I can be
relatively certain he was not an asset
for the can I just ask why can I just
ask why you so certain about this
because it it does seem to have been an
intelligence gathering operation of some
kind or
compromat.ru Coney Island he was very
curious he wasn't as smart as he thought
he was he didn't know as much about
science as he thought he did but I can
tell you that people like stepen Pinker
and people like Stephen Gould and people
like U the president of Harvard thought
he asked good questions during the
seminars that we all attended those
seminars I never attended a seminar
after um I represented him my
relationship did terminate I continued
to take his phone calls after that look
I don't know who Jeffrey Epstein is he
was very very I didn't even want to meet
him initially but uh lady rild assisted
and then some people at Harvard said
they wanted me to put together some
people to attend seminars of his and I
did that and um and and we learned a lot
I met people at Harvard that I had never
known even been on the faculty for 50
years men and women Vick let me just
come back to Vicky Ward quickly you've
been waiting patiently but um I mean a
man who appar L boasted to Associates
that he had compromising material film
footage and others of important
individuals and that's not the normal
way in which anyone behaves is
it right Douglas so I mean one thing we
did learn in the papers that came out
last night is that you know he did in
some of the depositions ask the women
who claimed that they were sent out to
men to give them very detailed
descriptions of what happened so that he
could use it to Blackmail them um I've
never seen that spelled out quite so
specifically before and then to your
point about you know the question who
was Jeffrey Epstein here's what we do
know that is not
speculative he did know the Crown Prince
of Saudi Arabia he did know Muhammad bin
zad the ruler of the uh United Arab
Emirates uh he did know very well ahud
Barack the former prime minister uh of
Israel that pictures of all of these men
he there's a picture of him uh I think I
believe with the Pope there was a
picture uh a picture of him of all sorts
of world leaders and and we know that
even after he got out of jail in 2010
you know um he he was clever enough to
use the connection he had with the
academics with the the former president
of Harvard with these other world
leaders to draw in other billionaires
like Bill Gates he understood how very
rich powerful people around the world
connect with each other he
understood what very rich powerful
people want from each other he
understood how to connect the plutocracy
and the elite does that mean he was an
asset
I don't you know there is there is
speculation but it it is he he
certainly was a manipulator of the
0.001% um Eric Weinstein quickly just
coming back to you if I may quickly um
uh I think a name that quite a lot of
people have been rather surprised to see
on this list for perhaps several reasons
is Professor the late professor Steven
Hawking uh what on Earth we meant to
make of
this well I mean there's two separate
things one is that uh the state of
physics uh is bizarre in that um it's
one of the most consequential things you
could possibly study for military
purposes um and at the same time it has
been sort of more or less run into the
ground um so Stephen Hawking was uh of
Interest probably for the same reason
that uh Jeffrey Epstein was much more
interested in talking to me about um
post Einstein steiny and gravity than he
was in talking about carry trades and
what professor dwit says is very strange
to me because he advertised to me that
he was a currency Trader uh running a
massive uh hedge fund out of theard
house in New York on Madison Avenue and
I dropped off documents there so
something is really not jelling and one
of the really interesting things would
be to have very extensive discussions uh
to try to figure out who this person is
because the person who presented himself
to me was much more like the person who
presented himself to Vicki than the
person who presented himself to Alan
dershwitz now what I would say is that
he had also extensive contacts
apparently with the Harvard mathematics
Department both through Benedict gross
and through uh Martin Noak um Harvard is
all through the story and as we are
learning Harvard is a very strange Place
uh I was there for about 20 years uh it
is sort of an extension of the US
government in an unacknowledged
capacity and it has the only University
to really have the power to effectively
change The Narrative of academics in
particular very consequential Fields now
the other thing about Stephen Hawking
that you should just know is you should
probably do a search on the word San
Bernardino and Stephen Hawking uh it was
not uh a secret that uh Professor ha
Hawking had a very healthy appetite for
life and that this is not new revelation
nor is the fact that he was associated
with Jeffrey Epstein uh a new revelation
so that there's something very peculiar
about the way in which we are forgetting
a tremendous amount I would also
recommend looking up the name Craig
Spence if the the suggestion that this
sounds like a completely insane idea
that he was connected to intelligence uh
Craig Spence is the antecedent
apparently of Jeffrey Epstein it's just
very strange that all these things made
the papers there's extensive
documentation on the internet we pretend
that we don't know let me just go Alan d
second he want to come back
in well of course he knew Stephen
Hawkings there are newspaper reports
about Stephen Hawkings having come to a
conference on his Island where he had
conferences so far not a single one of
the names that have come out has
surprised me I had heard all of it
before but as the judge in the second
circuit cabanis once said if there's an
accusation made in court papers it's to
be less believed than an accusation made
to the media because if the accusation
is made to the media and it's false you
can sue for defamation whereas if the
accusation is made in court papers
there's a privilege and so the judge
said look skeptically at accusations
made in court papers look I want
everything out I want all the theories
out there all the documents let the
public decide there are people who don't
want things they have things to hide but
people like me who have nothing to hide
who are not in any way embarrassed about
any of these Revelations because we know
we did nothing wrong we're the ones who
want all these papers out all these
documents out and I'm hoping the judge
will now release everything every single
document um I find that very interesting
because yeah yeah one of the things that
I find very intriguing is that Jeffrey
Epstein appeared to know all sorts of
things about me that were not public and
uh seem to require almost a periscope
into my life in particular scientific uh
things about me that uh probably flowed
through the Harvard Department that I
was from which I took my PhD I don't
think that you're grasping how strong
the circumstantial case is that this
person was somehow uh attached to
intelligence and may have benefited from
things like uh state secret privilege
and other forms of Exotica in the law
let me finish with just asking a very
quick but pretty important question of
each of you one by one if you may uh
just very quickly of course the other
thing that makes the whole thing bizarre
is the manner of his death did Jeffrey
Epstein kill himself
Vicki I think that whatever happened uh
he had help it didn't happen just by
himself Alan
dtz I have the same view I think he
probably killed himself probably paid
off guards to close the TV and other
things but I don't exclude the
possibility that there may have been a
third third parties involved I I'm not
sure that's why I want to complete
everything coming out enough speculation
enough inference let's get to the facts
and Eric
Weinstein if I had to speculate I would
say that I've never met a person less
likely to terminate his own life from
embarrassment than Jeffrey Epstein I
would put him first on the list of a
person who would be undaunted by being
worldwide known as a sex
off thank you very M thank you very much
Vicky ward in New York Alan duritz in
Delaware and Eric Weinstein in La it's a
great pleasure to have you all on thank
you now next on uncensored could Donald
Trump return to the White House and
could sir Kia starma be the UK's next
prime minister we'll look ahead to a
crucial year in
[Music]
politics we're here thanks for joining
us you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well you
know what I love about talk today we do
it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
the place to act without fear or favor
the co inquiry seems to have turned into
a sort of pantomim there's not really
any substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a FSE or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beeps and the clanks
and when it goes wrong unexpected item
in bagging area I know are we only going
to be trusting sources like meta and
Google where is our unbiased news going
to come from Gram was president of the
Cambridge unit which is the rubbish
version of being president of the Oxford
unit
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for living if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's about Twitter
you sons of can you please reinstate my
account thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this was
important after watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything shut down
Tik Tok problem solved when I say I am
God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a
rational talk TV is the only place where
you get the
truth this is talk
[Music]
TV welcome back to uncensored with me
Douglas Murray 2024 will be the biggest
election year in history more than 60
countries representing half the world's
population are going to be going to the
polls notably both the US and UK will
vote shaping not just their own fate but
the world's too As Trump Trump's
potential candidacy for 2024 looks ever
more likely the efforts to remove him
from the ballots raise a critical
question could these attempts
inadvertently play into his favor
actually bolstering his appeal among
supporters and contributing to a
narrative that fuels his political
Resurgence well joining me to discuss
this from Florida is the political
strategist and pster Frank luns also
here in London talk TV's International
editor Isabelle Oak shot along with
lawyer and writer Chris D thanks so much
for being with me everyone first of all
let me come to you uh Frank Lun I think
a lot of people watching might be
surprised by the possibility that uh
Donald Trump might be making a return to
the White House this year but it looks
possible yes it looks not only does it
look possible but at this point if the
election were held today it actually
looks likely Donald Trump has been
gaining over the last four months the
more indictments the higher his numbers
climb the more condemnation the higher
his numbers climb and you try to throw
him off the ballot his favorability
actually increases there's a level of
intensity a level of commitment among
his voters that does not exist for any
other candidate so I'd have to say at
this point Great Britain get ready
because Donald Trump May return and and
you think that if if Trump does get the
Republican nomination I mean he's still
if you add all the other candidates
together uh they still don't add up to
the amount of approval among the base
that Donald Trump has so it seems like a
dead set unless he's somehow knocked out
through legal reasons or something but
but but you're saying that you think
that that if it's Biden versus Trump a
replay wearing as it seems of 2020 you
think that uh the current polls Trump
beats
Biden at this point based on where the
economy is based on foreign policy
issues based on what's happening in the
Middle East and by by the way I'm so
glad to do this because sir you are a
hero in America they appreciate you
they're grateful for you speaking up and
I realize that this isn't quite what
this segment is about but I wanted to do
it to thank you for your wisdom thankk
you for your courage for your conviction
for telling the truth and that is what
Trump's people think of Donald Trump we
can disagree with him but make no
mistake his people believe that Donald
Trump tells the truth they believe it's
a Witch Hunt they believe he's a victim
they believe this is a persecution and
that's why they back him so strongly
well thank you very much for that Frank
L I'll come back to you but just with me
in the studio Isabel oaw if Donald Trump
does become president again in 2024 what
does that mean in Britain because this
country's government doesn't seem
prepared for it and a labor government
certainly wouldn't be well it means a
roller coaster ride I mean what it would
hopefully mean is that the UK us
relations become a little bit more
important again I mean Trump is an angle
file he loves this country he love the
queen he's very uh Pro the UK again it
might U raise some hopes of a um UK US
trade deal which seems to have
dissipated so I think in theory it would
be a good thing um but that said if we
have a starma government you know
probably less so well I was going to say
coming to you Chris D I mean if labor
were to win the election this year and
all again all of the polls would seem to
suggest that if Trump was in the White
House and starm is in number 10 what do
the special relationship look like well
I think the I think the more important
thing is it's frankly astonishing that
anyone thinks that a dangerous sociopath
and a a proven and and a habitual liar
like Donald Trump would be a good thing
for anyone particularly someone who has
expresses himself in so many dangerous
ways about world affairs particularly
his affinity for Vladimir Putin and so
forth so I I think it's so exaggerated
the whole Putin thing I mean it's such
an old lazy Trope as well I'm sorry to
bring up the whole oh Trump's really Pro
Russian I mean honestly I mean are we
going to really replay this whole thing
again well we're not replaying it
because the fact of is it's it's a truth
which people it's uncomfortable for
people but you're right it's one of the
many hundreds and hundreds of problems
with Trump as a politi what you just say
I mean I mean there was a whole thing
about the Russia gate conspiracy in the
US investigations and so on it came up
with a great big ber I mean isn't part
of the problem whatever your views on it
I mean that all the allegation there are
plenty of criticisms you can make of
Donald Trump but whenever you get into
the kind of you know Russian collusion
sort of stuff isn't that exactly the
sort of thing that makes voters do what
Frank L is pointing to which is they say
you know everyone's being lying about
this guy we don't believe anything that
the media says we don't believe anything
the commentators say we're just going to
stick with him because he's our guy yeah
you're absolutely right and and what
that says about the vacuum in our
politics not just not just in the United
States but in the United Kingdom is
really tragic isn't it that we have an
octogenarian or almost one we have an
octogenarian president neither of whom
really are fit to govern remotely fit to
govern anything let alone the most
powerful country in the world where are
the young people where are the dynamic
inspirational leaders who can appeal to
the whole of the population rather than
just narrow partisan well I want to
bring Frank Lun back in on that because
uh Frank Lun if you've just been
listening to that uh we do have young
leaders in in the UK compared to America
uh not everyone in UK politics has to be
an octogenarian um but would you say
that uh that the youth that is on rishy
sunak side and slightly on Kama side as
well do you think it's an electoral
Advantage for either of them I don't
think it gives an advantage but most
certainly if you're as old as Joe Biden
and have trouble completing sentences
and doing press conferences and all the
things that we expect of a presidential
candidate I've heard that the strategy
you can see moving off that plane very
quickly
that's not what he does in most of the
appearances people watch him and they
think thank you sir for your governance
thank you for putting America back on
the right track but it's time for you to
go but but if he does go Frank Ian isn't
the problem I mean the Republicans have
quite a bit of talent actually
underneath Donald Trump in my view there
there's a lot of experienced Governors
and others seems that underneath Joe
Biden in the Democratic party there's
very little I mean they're not going to
run camela Harris are they I mean she's
got roughly the same approval ratings as
the Ebola virus yes she's that's a very
good line uh she's the least popular
vice president since Dan quail and he
was the least popular vice president
Since Aaron Burr you're correct she is
not going to be by the way that's how I
can tell if anybody watch watch the play
Hamilton uh she is not going to be the
nominee but there is Corey Booker the
senator from New Jersey there's
uh uh
gav Gavin Newsome these are people from
the Next Generation anyone any of these
candidates would run better against
Donald Trump than Joe Biden so we have
to wonder why don't they give someone
else who's younger the chance well the
truth of it is ego ego I'm afraid and
and the the hunger for power at all
costs on the part of U of President
Biden which is utterly tragic for the
American people but sadly is likely to
lead to an inevitable consequence well
talking of a desire for power at all
costs Isabel Oak shot uh the
conservative party still said to be
plotting against rishy sunak all sorts
of internal embroiling going
on is the conservative party ever going
to pull itself together and survive the
next I thought what you were going to
say is holding on to power at all costs
by pushing the election out as far as
they
can know go and this was quite a
significant intervention it didn't
strike me as games playing you know he
very naturally said look my working
assumption is second half of this year I
think most of us have really thought
that's when it would be he still of
course has it in his gift to suddenly
say in a few weeks time if something
extraordinary happens and suddenly
fortunes look better for the
conservatives he could suddenly say
actually I'm going to go to the country
in May and just quickly reform do they
chip away at the conservative vote I
think the important thing is that they
will also chip away at Labour's vote and
quite significantly if labor don't start
saying something much tougher on
immigration that's going to be a real
problem for them uh quick lightning
round Frank Lun you think that Donald
Trump's most likely to be president in
the United States this time next year at
a 5149 Advantage yes and uh who would
you bet on as the next prime minister of
the United Kingdom I bet that labor wins
by a reasonably significant margin Chris
yeah absolutely I think that spot on I
think tragically um we have a a void in
our politics of of really powerful
inspirational political Leaders with
policies that have Broad and act would
make a difference in our society and
that means we're left we're left with
the the dross basically on both sides of
the Atlantic I don't you just describe
uh K stor as drw no not personally but
the labor the labor party check Labor's
not an inspirational party I don't think
they're really getting people on fire in
this country and and until that happens
as it did of course with Tony Blair in
97 we're not going to see that kind of
movement that makes for real change and
real power in the hands of the
government you agree I want to see a
hung Parliament so that the people
country get proportional representation
people are too disenfranchised no I
agree proportional representation
there's a in the country for it I tell
it I tell you what happens with what
happens with proportional representation
is you get Italy no you don't but anyway
um we can come back to that another
night thank you all for being with me
and thank you to FR Frank Lun over there
in the US now up next on uncensored
trigger warnings and storylines
dominated by identity politics is the
diversity and inclusion agenda ruining
TV and film I'm going to be joined by
Notting Hill gimme gimme gimme and The
Thin Blue Line star the great actor
James
[Music]
draus we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about to today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming round the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and rishy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear all favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million pound so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking liit if you're walking towards
me and you're a vegan she have a great
big orange sticker over here saying
watch out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walked into a
branch of McDonald M Mouse man MC mous M
he should be easy enough to catch this
guy shouldn't he I mean he's got house
full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of Reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to resign yes cuz I cannot
continue my work when I say I am God I'm
not joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call H terror group is
it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should a m stay
in power and are there terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that this is talk
TV on the show tonight she's the woman
that organized an interview with gain
Maxwell uh that we showed here on talk
TV earlier this year she's closer to the
Epstein story than almost anyone and
we're going to be getting some very
interesting info from her also why on
Earth are the police in London
investigating war crimes in Israel it's
all coming up at
[Music]
9: welcome back to uncensored the
British Film Institute has issued the
early films in the James Bond series
with trigger warnings and it's not for7
golden gun but because they could cause
offense today and it's not just James
Bond that's been shaken if not a bit
stirred with woke controversy the new
Doctor Who was introduced to us at
Christmas shaking his thing in a
fetching muscle top and skirt whilst
Star Wars announced that their next film
will be directed by a feminist who says
she enjoys making men feel
uncomfortable it does really seem like
South Park hit the nail on the head with
this recent
skit Put Another Gay diverse woman in it
make it more lame going
my is there a problem people we were
just discussing a ideas of what to do
with the new Prince Eric movie put a
chicken it make her gay maybe we should
go a different route than we did with
Indiana Jones Indiana Jones put a
chicken in and make her L and
gay so is this really the the future of
what we'll be watching in
2024 joining me now to discuss this is
the actor James draus James thank you so
much for being with me H Mr Murray we
meet it last
I yeah um tell me uh this I we start
let's start with James Bond uh does it
surprise you that James Bond now needs a
trigger warning no it doesn't surprise
me in the slightest to be honest with
you I mean I've just read their their
statement about it which is whilst we
have a responsibility to preserve films
as close to their temporaneous accuracy
as possible uh we also have a
responsibility in how we present them to
our audiences well no you don't yeah
what does that mean I well I don't know
what it means I mean back in the day uh
we had u a a ax all seemed pretty clear
and the Bond movies um I seem to
remember were okay they're not aimed at
children like like Doctor Who is but uh
the James Bob movies were teenage
fair I I can't even begin to think why
any of them have a trigger warning least
of all for John Barry's music you know
one of one of the things that amazed me
about this James you I always sort of
think we seem to be run by cultural
juveniles um if I'm just trying to think
back on the BFI released movies that
I've seen in the past I remember about
25 years ago they released all of the
Great works of directors like eisenstein
Pier Paulo pasolini I saw Pier Pao
pasolini's salow I wouldn't recommend it
to viewers any more than I would
recommend some of the things that Eric
Weinstein was recommending you look up
in relation to Stephen Hawking earlier
but um Salo is probably the most
disgusting film I've ever seen and it's
based on the Marquee dards 120 days of
Sodom if they're going to start putting
trigger warnings on James Bond I reckon
the 120 days of Sodom probably needs uh
some some other kind of extreme warning
well you know something Douglas I get
nervous when I now see films without a
trigger warning because I think um oh my
God you know what what's in this I mean
I was watching a film this morning I I
love watching horror films I'll give you
an example and there was a warning at
the start of this movie which was given
by the um uh the directors actually
saying we're warning you that sudden
shots in this film will contain
something that upset you in the name of
humanity and then I thought okay well
I'll steal myself a little bit uh and
the first image I saw was a baby seal
being clubbed to death in real life and
so I immediately turned it off and I
thought oh my God and it's Disturbed me
all
day that I can understand epilepsy
warnings I can
understand um but when you're talking
about things like James Bond or even
cartoons I mean if you really want to
go back put put put a disclaimer in
front of Bambi want to ship down that's
the most those are the most disturbing
movies I've ever seen I don't understand
it but it gives me a clue here when they
say we listen to customer
feedback and also continue to work
closely with blah blah blah now that
tells me that they're listening to all
the people that
complain not the people that they'll
never them up and say yeah well so um
that brings me on to Doctor Who because
uh you've been involved in Doctor Who
and Doctor Who in recent years really
has been following the advice of Eric
Cartman In that clip and being they've
been putting a chick in everything and
making it lame and as gay as possible
and not in a good way um what has
happened to it and what was your own
experience with Doctor Who well I had no
I had no experience of Doctor Who until
I was asked to play the master by big
finish um and and I signed a letter
asking Stonewall for a debate and
defending JK Rowling from having death
threats and I thought everyone else in
the world would sign it but apparently
not and apparently then a petition was
sent to uh this organization and I was
ceremoniously dumped but I wasn't even
told so I've heard nothing from them so
you you weren't in Doctor Who because
you supported JK
Rowling they erased me from
uh uh or the I found out because they'
erased me from the front of the CDs they
did a um a show called
masterful which had a compilation of all
the Masters that had been played on
audio and thing and I was left out of
that and all they did was put out this
rather ambiguous message that
transphobia will not be tolerated in any
shape or form which basically said we
believe you are a transphobe and uh why
why are they even in this business James
I mean let me let me just play you a
quick clip this is something from from
the new Doctor Who I can't understand
how anyone thinks this is entertainment
let's roll
this yes the Meep I promise I can help
him get home and then you'll never see
me again you're assuming he as a
pronoun true yes sorry good point are
you he or she or they My Chosen pronoun
is the definite article I am always the
me I just is this is this is like this
is instruction not
entertainment well of course it is it's
I mean I've always said you know that
this pronoun business is not a question
it's a test it's a yeah it's a test and
it's now become sort of part of regular
daily life I mean the fact of the matter
is is still you know the vast majority
of people don't understand don't
understand all this um children don't
understand it I've had members of my
family um you know younger members
completely confused by this stuff and I
don't I don't really understand what's
it got to do with um enter it seems like
it's no longer just entertainment it
always has to have some sort of message
and the message is quite Niche yes as
niche as possible it seems and
as as unamusing as possible and as Bland
as possible and as predictable as
possible it's like seeing an entire
culture just sort of made to be exactly
the same across the board yeah that's
that's how it seems to me but but the
only positive I can see out of this
Douglas is that eventually uh you know
this this mask will
slip this Niche will uh be borrowed into
so so deeply that um um people cannot
ignore it any longer so I'm hoping that
this is a you know a circle uh that will
eventually end and we'll just get back
to entertaining people I mean Doctor Who
is for children and and it surprises me
that they they slipped this in because
it's obviously nothing to do with Doctor
Who it's to do with this ideology that's
happening at the moment and very quickly
uh James draus uh how come it seems now
that everyone's saying you got to be gay
to play a gay character you got to be
trans to play a trans character but yet
your former co-star uh from nottinghill
uh Hugh Grant is allowed to play an Umpa
lumper without actually himself being an
Umpa lumper what the explanation for
that well it's I'm it's extraordinary I
don't know how he got the part not being
a LPA Loa um that's the the one what I
don't understand is is you have people
like Peter Dinkley saying look we've
grown we've grown out of this snow white
the Seven walls of us have all having
living in a cave or whatever uh which
denies work then to Little People actors
and we're talking about one person the
last Wily Wonka film had the same person
reproduced over and over and over again
I think this is something that's you
know it everyone wants to be this is
what happens when you have identity
politics in the AR everyone wants to be
a pie
of much person thanks so much for that
it's been such a pleasure to have you on
uh that's it from me and it's been a
great pleasure being with you all of
this week sadly Piers is back on Monday
until then whatever you're up to make
sure it's uncensored good
night
[Music]
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
using XL Bully dogs as weapons to th
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn do you know what I love
about talk today we do it all sunak
sella
scun I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
down to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the Tories love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the track
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and richy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what Rashi sunak has done the
question now is what he does next the
police appr Pro Palestine that is just
not right you swear an o in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pant mind there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk TV
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for Sadi Khan we're not stopping until
you
stop the amount of time it's taken the
number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million so far so £140 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come
Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking liit if you're walking towards
me and you're a vegan you have a great
big orange sticker over here saying
watch out vegan
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in about three years hundreds and
hundreds of mice in a box which he walks
into a branch of McDonald MC Mouse man
MC mous man M he should be easy enough
to catch this guy shouldn't he I mean
he's got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this is important